As you know, Marty said that a lot of the thought is you stay all theme park,
ride, Marty, what are you doing?
Your iron man portrayal has become the thing. It is a huge moneymaker. Yeah.
You still enjoy doing it. Yes, it is.
This very large multi-headed Hydra at this point, according to Scorsese,
it's not cinema. I got to take a look at that, but it is cinema, isn't it?
I mean, it plays in theaters like saying, you know, bug money. Ain't funny.
You know, I think in his view, we're, uh,
denigrated the, the, the art, the era,
the art form of cinema going to the movies used to be an experience.
People will go see movies just because they said is going to be
number one, the value. How do you,
I don't want to say the value of a film. That's like a theme park film,
for example, and the Marvel type pictures. Cause not cinema,
it's something else.
And we need the theater owners to step up for that to allow theaters,
to show films that are narrative films.
He got a lot of heat for it, but I understand fully what you were saying.
They always felt cut from the same cloth in that they were very big and
event and CGI spectacles. To some extent I was thinking at the time,
what would it be like to really strip it all down and do,
and do a really intimate character study or you explore one of these characters
in an intense way.
Was inspired by your sin. I know by your movies,
but do you also consider it as a theme park movie? I don't know about that.
I know the film very well and I know Todd very well. Mike producer, Dylan,
Schakowsky produced it. So, um, it's an interesting question.
No, one's laughing. We're not laughing at the clamps.
I don't want to be down on the clowns. We are colleagues in a certain sense,
comedians and clown, comedians and clowns,
but we all know somewhere underneath all of that bright color,
there is a man who's not right. At some point, he's got to wash his face,
taking his pants and start dealing with life. Like
let us go to Matt and say hello to the very talented Joaquin Phoenix.
[inaudible] thank you very much for being on the program. Again, you know,
it's been three years since the last time you were on the show and I will just
say right off the top, here you look different than I remember.
This is exactly how I imagined it. Well,
that makes one of us.
We've got a nice beard going and Oh yeah. I was at the beard
[inaudible] I watched that whole interview. And I said to myself, well, Kane,
Phoenix is a genius.
That was like the greatest press parents I've ever seen in my life were terrific
in the film. I really enjoyed your work. Thank you.
This is how brilliant it is.
Basically what he's doing is resisting every protocol of what it's like to be on
a late night talk shows you and a piece of cardboard in your room.
I'm making fun of it, but.
And then do any of the banter. He didn't do any of that. Hey, good to be here.
David got a new movie coming up. Can we move on? Yes.
And he's a completely different kind of celebrity than I am by design of what he
does. He's a fine actor.
You have a tendency to make things up.
You lie on talk shows every time I've ever seen you.
When you see walking in Kleenex,
he's in a movie pretending to be somebody completely different and he's
very good at it. So you can't tell what he's actually like.
Bad news for Marvel fans looking to see what keen Phoenix in the role of Dr.
Strange as word is the actor has dropped out of talks with the comic book diet.
The 43 year old actor was reportedly the first choice to replace that Horton as
the Hulk, but passed on the opportunity.
You've said in the past that you would do a comic book movie,
if the right role came up.
Why was this the right role for you?
Can you just say it was complex in a way that the other movies
that I kind of flirted with?
Weren't probably why I ultimately said yes to the movies because I wasn't
sure of what I felt about him. I liked that space. Um, um, I'm,
I'm comfortable there. I don't need all the answers. It just seemed to me,
no matter what the character is, it just sort of,
you're going along the journey with that character. You may like the character.
You may not, but it's just that you're interested in the character.
[Inaudible].
Movie and what Todd Phillips is doing.
And it as a director and how it's being written is so
Scorsese at times, it's it has so much taxi driver.
You got some bad ideas in my head. I just hold on.
Have negative thoughts.
And so much King of comedy in it. This is how I see you.
You could say something like this, one small thing. Yeah.
Bring me out. Can you introduce me as joker? At that time,
there were so many films and we wonder wonderful actors between these characters
where we didn't really know fully understand what their motivation was.
And we were okay with that.
It was always to give off this kind of unsettling vibe of this guy who was
pretty much separated from everybody else. Even in this locker room,
space alone, kind of, not part of the group.
I always tried to shoot Bob a single frame on his shot. However,
when you take other people, we try to shoot, pass him,
include him in their frames. We try to keep him separate from everybody else.
Larry and I really chose to shoot a ton of this really long lens.
So you have that real shallow depth of field that you see in some of those old
school movies did them. The 600.
The longest lens I tried to do was really isolate him.
I tried to isolate him from other people, but he him completely.
Soft focused. And he's kind of floating through the city.
When you make a movie about one person of the other element becomes a
character.
If the music is suddenly a character and the locations are suddenly character
shoot this scene against Columbus circle. So we'd see the life we see the city.
The city is like really a character in this movie too. You know,
we wanted this movie to feel like it could have come out in the summer of 1979.
I'm doing the commentary here. Now I see this. And it's a pretty,
pretty close sense of New York in the late seventies. You know,
You know that scene where he's dancing in the bathroom is scripted as an
entirely different scene. Good.
I believe had a saying that he was preparing in front of the mirror and I was
saying to him, I really think we need for you to speak in the mirror,
speak to yourself in the mirror. Yeah.
He goes into this little rundown bathroom in a rundown park and he is going to
wash his makeup off and hide the gun under a thing. And when meanwhile came,
we're on the set and we're just like, man,
this doesn't really feel like the Arthur we've been filming now for four or five
weeks. Not him. It was the last week of shooting.
We over-schedule five days in America. It was very difficult. And we said, okay,
we're just going to shoot this scene and uh, locked the door.
So our assistant director wouldn't get it.
And so we sat around for 45 minutes while you know, the crews outside,
just thinking about other possibility Ady was banging on the door, come on,
we gotta get out of here. And I said, let's, she's good. This is good.
Just wait, give me another minute. I called the operator.
Didn't even tell the operator what we're doing. I just said, start on his foot.
Yeah, that was sort of at his feet in front of the mirror,
right in front of him. And he started improvising it and he kept saying,
are you talking to me? And just started playing the score from off of my iPhone.
And he started doing this dance, then that was it. Um, but he just kept,
he went on a roll. Yeah.
You talking to me talking to me.
Go ahead and produce this film. Your, your partner, Emma, is the producer on it.
Why did you decide not to, uh, personal reasons?
I think for me also scheduling and primary, I mean, quite honestly,
a taxi driver and King of comedy and lasting patient of Christ.
Those were my fights. You've got to start.
The bottom.
I know that's where I am at the bottom because comedy is a very weird film,
but it has a lot in common with a taxi driver.
Both are stories about outsiders who want to be insiders. Hi Eliza.
Let's see Gerald. Good to see Jerry. Don't get up. Hey Mary,
thank you so much for having me on the show. It's been a lifetime view of mine.
Yeah.
Joker has a certain kind of arrogance and this needs to be
revered and adored. He sees himself as, as a King in some way,
or looking at the King of comedy. This was not a pleasant guy.
And the question is, I think filmmakers, filmmaker.
Say, you have to like your characters. I don't think Scorsese likes this.
You don't give a about people like you are there.
And they really don't give a about people like that.
Me, I think I had such mixed feelings about the character as I,
as I went through the script and everybody that I included in my family have a
different reaction to the character,
into the movie and what it means and how it,
whether they should sympathize or not.
I think it's that I look at my whole life and I see the awful,
terrible things in my life and turn it into something funny.
I used to think that my life was a tragedy,
but now I realize it's a comedy.
And that's what I like about the movie. Right? It's not that ACTIC,
it's not telling you precisely what you should feel a win.
And I think that's rare in movies.
[inaudible]
you said decent [inaudible].
Oh, Jesus.
[inaudible]. I don't know. I mean, I know when I see it to see
it, I know. I don't know. You know, when there's an officer there and you know, when it's personal and you know,
anything
, you can feel it, you can feel it come through every moment, every shot every and the actors and every piece of it and it, and it just doesn't miss you. And I don't know that I can explain it better than that.
I'm walking in.
I spend six months talking about the movie before we shot the first frame of the
movie.
So all we did was collaborate and talk about ways to do scenes approaches to the
character tone. Talk about telling him how the movie is going to look.
When you guys sit down.
And when you first receive a script for one of these things,
do they consult with you? Do they discuss this with you? I think the phrase,
the legal phrase for actors and studios is meaningful consultation. Uh,
not script approval.
That'd review dailies, and I'd go through the script.
So I would just have like still have questions.
And so I would call him for two hours. We would talk like almost every day.
Getting a pretty brutal education on what kind of process these
movies require.
You just start trusting more that they're thinking on your behalf.
It was exciting to me to see no matter how detailed and how
well we wrote a script for him to come in and make it his own.
That is literally what people mean. I think when they say the magic of movies,
that's the magic part. Occasionally in art,
you get lucky and you're at the right place at the right time with the right
people. And I think that was the case with taxi driver. This something that.
Schrader and Scorsese are learning from the French new wave from people like
John Lucco, Dawn and Francois Truffaut, and other filmmakers that were very,
very powerful influences at the time.
There was greatly inspired by the works of Martin Scorsese and Sydney lament,
and other filmmakers that I sort of grew up worshiping in the seventies and
early eighties.
Every film that you make is a celebration of filmmaking.
And part of that celebration is to allude to them, to give a nod.
[Inaudible].
Joker taxi driver and King of comedy all had clear directorial, visions,
complete creative control, and just strong actor, director collaboration.
Those ingredients made those movies great.
And the ingredients don't require a big budget or fancy equipment.
If you have a vision and want to make your own film,
you have all you need to get started and to help make that vision come to life,
you can join Ryan booze class on making your own videos.
Look like a movie on Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community that offers membership with meaning
through its classes on topics like filmmaking, video editing,
or photography with so much to explore real projects to create.
And the support of fellow creatives Skillshare empowers you to accomplish real
growth. The first 500 of my subscribers to click the link in the description,
we'll get two free months of premium membership.
So you can explore your creativity.
That includes Ryan Booth class plus thousands of others that give you the
opportunity to learn and discover new things.
Thanks to Skillshare for sponsoring this video and thanks to my Patrion
supporters for making this channel possible. Thanks for watching.